hey everyone welcome back let's write
some more neat code today today let's
solve remove nth node from the end of a
list
so we're given a linked list and all we
need to do
is remove the nth node from the end of
the list
and then return the new list so that's
pretty straightforward right so in this
case we got five nodes
we just want to remove the n equals two
so meaning the second node from the end
of the list right so this is the first
from the end of the list this is the
second
so we remove this and then we return
this list which now has four elements
remaining
so what's the easiest way to solve this
well they say from the
end of the list that's inconvenient if
it was from the beginning of the list
it'd be
super straightforward right n equals 2
remove this node
how can we make that even easier i mean
what if these pointers were reversed
can't we just reverse this linked list
start from
here and then remove the second node
and then we're done that's definitely a
possible solution but it requires
reversing the linked list which we don't
actually
have to do and i'm going to show you the
easier way to do it
so let's say n equals 2 again
so we want to remove this node so how
can we
identify that this is the second node
from the end of the list
like a lot of linked list questions we
can use two pointers
but how are we gonna make use of our two
pointers
so what if i had two pointers right a
left pointer and a right pointer
the left pointer is at the beginning of
the list and the right pointer
is shifted by n equals two so
our right pointer is gonna be shifted
one and then it's gonna be shifted again
and our right pointer is gonna be over
here so
now we're just gonna keep shifting our
pointers until this
right pointer is at the end of the list
and watch what happens
when we do that so we're just going to
be shifting
each pointer by one and this is going to
make sure
that the space between these pointers is
exactly
equal to n which is two right
so now we're going to shift by one again
making sure that the gap between them is
still two
now we're going to shift one last time
because right is almost at the end so
now our
right pointer is at null right it's at
the
end of the list it can't go any farther
and our left pointer
is exactly at the node that we want to
delete
and the reason is because remember the
offset between these two
is n making sure that we have the node
we want to delete
now there's only one problem we have
access to the node that we want to
delete but we want to delete it
how do we delete it the only thing we
have to do is take this pointer
cross it out and then reassign it
over here right once we've done that
we've gotten
rid of this node so the problem is
we're at this node when really we want
to be
at this node if we want to delete this
node
and this can actually be solved by
another
pretty common technique the dummy node
right so we're going to actually have
another
node that we insert at the beginning of
this list that we don't really
use and the main thing that's going to
happen is happen is instead of our
left pointer instead of our left pointer
being initialized here
we're actually going to initialize it at
the dummy node
so left is really going to be
initialized here
and our right pointer though is still
going to be initialized over here
so in reality when our right pointer
reaches the end of the list
we will have a left pointer at 3
and then we can update its pointer
removing this node that we want to
remove
and to return the new linked list
all we have to do is take our dummy
pointer
and say return dummy dot next
which is going to be this node and since
this is a 2.0 technique
the time complexity is going to be big o
of n
so just like in the drawing the first
thing we really want to do is create a
dummy node
we don't really care what the value of
this node is but i'll just say
zero but we want to make sure that the
next
pointer of this node is set to the head
of the list because we're inserting it
at the beginning
next we can initialize our left
pointer to dummy
and we want our right pointer to be
head plus two right or
head plus n whatever n happens to be
so we need a loop to do that right we
can't just do that
with a calculation so we can initially
say
right is equal to head and while
n is greater than zero and
right is not null we want to keep
shifting right
so shift right by one
and decrement n by one
because once n equals zero that means
we've shifted by the amount that we
wanted to shift by
and the last thing we want to do is keep
shifting
both of our pointers now now we're
shifting left and right and we're going
to keep
going until right equals until
right reaches the end of the list
so we can shift our left pointer
and we can shift our right pointer
now last but not least we actually want
to delete the node and remember
all we need to do to delete is update
the left node's next pointer
and it's going to basically be shifted
by one so left dot next is going to
equal
left dot next dot next
so for example if my left node was at
my left pointer was at this node its
next pointer is at 2 but i want to set
its next pointer
to 2's next pointer so
basically what i'm doing is this and we
know that
dummy.next is at the head of our list
which is what we want to return we want
to return the
updated list so we can just return
dummy.next we don't want to include
our dummy node in the output we never
wanted to add a node to the list we just
wanted to remove a node
so our solution works beautifully we
could have just reversed the list
but we definitely did not need to do
that i hope this was helpful
don't forget to like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon